Hey, Gagan.
So do you think, Jain?
Hello, hello.
How do you find time for this meetings?
Oh, Natalie is here.
Hello, special, special guest appearance. Oh, thanks, Jason.
Natalie there.
Natalie, Natalie got a new picture. Natalie got a new picture. What's happening, Natalie?
Hey, Jason, good afternoon.
Jason heard the noise. I mean, sort of some sort of celebration.
Reid.
Jason, Jason.
Jason would, Jason would be like, what's happening?
I didn't know what I joined. However, you all will not be able to see me today. My camera this morning froze and then doesn't work anymore. So I'll have one between 5 and 10 P.m. Eastern today. However, that's right. You all know what I'm looking at. You get the much younger version of me here in my profile pic.
The.
Yeah.
Yeah, we actually can. We can't see your profile picture. It just says JC, but it's okay. We believe you. Yeah, it doesn't actually transfer. I always thought that as well, that like if you were in teams, like they could still see your picture, but yeah, you can't see it on the other side.
that I don't have all the gray hair so look at that.
Oh, really? That's that's...
I know.
That's.
Or maybe if maybe some added security by Jason, you know, for to prevent it from external people to see it.
Yeah.
Yeah, they don't want to see how good you, how good looking you are in your younger days. Can only keep it internal.
You know, maybe, I don't know.
Yep, exactly.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Alright, but yeah, we were just joking around when you jumped on, so, but now we're ready for business.
S.
No worries, no worries.
Well, I'm on the wrong call then.
I
All right, Gagan.
All right.
Thank you, Kevin. Thank you, Michelle. And thank you, Sarah, for joining in as well.
On your time.
Just now, are we expecting anyone else, Cindy or maybe Eric, to join in?
I think so. Cindy's on Cindy's on lunch.
Okay.
Um, she had to take a lunch at this point and then, nah, nobody else, just me.
All right, thank you, so.
I think it's a good time to start now.
And just as good as any.
Team, are we good? Is there anything from anyone before we start? I mean, I start my presentation.
Michelle Kevin.
Nope, it's all you.
Hey, Gagan.
All right, thank you, sir.
I mean, I'll just want the update on, you know, Manish as well. So if that's in there, then we just rock'n'roll whenever it's appropriate.
Absolutely, I think we were just discussing it. That is, that would be the very first point I added in my presentation.
Awesome.
Please let me know once my screen is visible on your screens.
Yep.
I gotta.
Thank you. So we are doing in the month of June. However, this is for the previous month. So which is why I'm in.
It is showing June here, so I mean, no, Natalie is here, so you can see that, uh, Natalie must be in this picture. Uh, I think this is of one of the previous builder events, right?
I am.
Yeah, this was the one two years ago from Orlando. And this was like right after they did like the military boot camp thing. That's why everyone's sweaty.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right, moving on to agenda items.
Yeah.
Yes, we have just some highlights, performance analysis, way forward with summit business technology, AI by design, holiday schedule, and recap, which of course I do send after this call, along with MREMS.
Thank you. I don't have to say that, you know, you know the drill. So if you have any questions, feedback, or suggestions, please feel free to chime in. I mean, this is for everyone. So thank you, team. All right, thank you. Moving on to highlights, not captured much, but so health updates, Marcus is making good progress on his health recovery.
Will do.
I just spoke to, you know, a few days back. Instead, he called me up. So it was very pleasant to receive a call from Marcus and he said, yeah, I mean, he felt sorry that, I mean, the very first time when I visited the hospital, I mean, because of medication, I mean,
He has a little difficulty, but now he is making good progress and a physiotherapist is visiting his place. And so he has started to, you know, walk with some support. So I'm sure in a few weeks, you know, he'll be working on his own.
And so, if we see from from the.0 when he fell ill to to the current state, he has made good progress.
Right.
That's good to hear, yeah.
And we, just like you, I mean his family and all of us, we are waiting for him to recover fully so that he can join his team back. Yeah, this is what we are hopeful for.
About Akhilesh, I'm sure. I mean, you do check his board when you get time. So he is making good progress, consistently improving and becoming more self-reliant. So Cindy was asking me the other day, hey, Gagan, what have you done? I mean, he is.
You know, checking with him very less and handling most of his stuff, you know, on his own. So, did he get some pill or or is your ITBD team supporting him? So, I said, I mean both of both of these two things, so he has been asked to.
I mean, he has been given all sort of, you know, sessions by me. He understands things. He understands the objective, how he needs to accomplish those things. So when he has technical issue, so ITBD team, my own team, this is, that's the one he reaches out first and.
If he has any process related query, so definitely he reaches out to Cindy or Samit's team.
I would like to hear more from you on this, although I mean, we do connect on a weekly basis sometimes. Jason, any more insights from you?
I mean, my understanding is he's continuing to, you know, improve. We were finding some other things that he may be able to do. We've got like reboots of computers, follow-ups and things like that. So I think things are continuing to go. I appreciate the support with that because we really needed to have
It wasn't at a lack of his efforts or what the expectations were. It's just our business needed a more immediate relief from getting all the work done, you know. So the fact that you all were able to help bridge some of that gap there and maybe get him going was really helpful. We just didn't have the time for him to come up to speed. So
Yep.
If Cindy's seen the difference, then that's great. I mean, I'll be...
Honest, I've been, we had a lot of projects going on that have been going really well. And the fact that I haven't been being pulled into things means that things must be going well because otherwise I'd be being pulled in left and right.
Okay.
So I don't have anything but positive at this point. I think we'll continue to find ways to.
Yeah.
Uh, utilize them and continue to utilize them more, so.
Thank you very much, Jason, for sharing this feedback. Absolutely. Our core focus is to just keep things stable and so that he matches his pace with the team so that, I mean, he starts to add value. Firstly, of course, meeting his KPI targets in the 1st place.
So when I do board reviews, you know, my focus is to, you know, ask for the previous feedback that you had shared for Manish as well and for Akhilesh as well when he joined in last month on the 1st. So his documentation is very strong. I mean, so one thing I like about him is I should not be impressing myself, but just like me,
He's very good at documentation. I mean, whenever any feedback is given to him, he embraces that, openly accepts the feedback, and starts working on it immediately. So when I ask him, I mean, he has the answer. So he knows.
Right.
Yeah.
the flow of the issue resolution as soon as he takes the ticket, so he understands. If he does not understand, he has to look at the previous ticket, so the same summary for the client. He also needs to look for some documentation internally. If that is something technical, he reaches out to my team. If that is the process later, as I said, so.
then the last resort is reaching out to, you know, Cindy or Summit team, because we know that they may be working on some other stuff and everyone's time is important and expensive. So we do not want to harm their
Productive productive time, so thank you for sharing this feedback.
Moving on to performance analysis, the actual data, yeah, for the month of May. I know in the initial phase, Team supported very well, Cindy, you. So he was not born better with a lot of tasks. So slowly and gradually he was given.
Task accordingly, so that he can digest and move along accordingly. So, which is why we see numbers are not in the way in the very first month, so numbers are not touching the target that we have set for a tenured engineer, you know, who needs to be meeting these targets. However, he is...
very close to meeting these targets. So his billable remains 67% and non-billable 11%. And we see right from the first week onwards, so he's 74, close to 70, 68. And then in the last week, it was a little less.
Depending upon the tickets he gets, I can share more insights on it on our separate call as well about my board view information that I get.
Yeah, so we know that in the initial phase that he spent more time in learning, understanding the environment and summit business technology specific process and procedure. This is where he spent most of his time understanding the process. I'm sure gradually.
Yeah.
In this month, for once we'll present June's months data, so you will see drastic improvement.
Team anything from anyone.
Jason, any questions, concerns, or suggestions on this one utilization part?
****** up now.
Okay, I appreciate that. Yeah, just to add one thing, all the great work that Akhilesh is doing, definitely Gagan is working in the background with him, but I'll definitely give some credit to Cindy as well, because Gagan has initial or settled some touch base with her. I'm not sure if that is happening.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
every day. Initially we were doing that. I was a part of those conversations, a quick 10 minute conversation, but that was very helpful where Akhilesh was able to, you know, get everything from Cindy, what he was doing good, where he needs a support. So I really appreciate Cindy's support on this one.
Absolutely, Michelle. Thank you for sharing this. Yeah, so every day, so Cindy and I, we get on a call. If we do not have time to get on a call, we at least touch base on Team text. She, you know, I text her and she responds to me that, yeah, he is doing good and these are the tickets, you know, he did well on.
And these are some more tickets she has put on his plate and he's taking care of those. Yeah.
Right.
Yeah, she sent me a message. I don't know if it was this morning or yesterday. She says, I've loaded a kill up. I was like, all right, awesome. So she said that.
Yeah, close to 40 tickets. Absolutely. So he was asking me, my board view for today is still pending with him, and so most of those are patching tickets. My team is well equipped with the patching stuff, but however, if there are some internal specific...
process that you follow in patching, so I'll refer to your team on that. Otherwise, from a technical standpoint, we'll equip him with all the understanding.
Okay.
Thank you. Moving on to ticket resolve rates. So yeah, this needs some improvement. Although I mean, he tells a good number, 171, out of which he was able to resolve 79. So it, you know, that it doesn't mean that he did not close more tickets than 79. So these are the tickets.
purely, which was able to complete the same day. However, he was able to close more tickets than this, but we are very particular about what is this daily closure rate.
So as we see in the first week initially, that was his very first initial week. So he just charged 34 tickets of which he was able to complete 18. Then the number picked up to 47, then 46, 44, so close to
you know, between 45 and 50 and was able to complete, yeah, close to, I would say, 45 to 50% of the tickets. As I said, same thing. So this initial month, his focus was more to understand the process, understand the tool sets that.
some of the business technologies using and understanding the client environment, who is the PSC, from who he needs to get approval on certain things. I mean, because at the same time, when I was connecting with them, giving him all the knowledge and understanding, so I think he was...
At the same time, he was feeling a little under pressure, was refraining from making mistakes. So that was also one thing which took a little extra. But we will be seeing some more better numbers going forward. Jason, anything from your end?
Nope, nothing on my end. I mean, I think things are going in the right direction from what Cindy's telling me. I mean,
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you on that.
Way forward, as I shared in the beginning, so our definitely focus is to, you know, I'm consistently in touch with Marcus and so he's making good progress and we really want him to join back our team so that he can he can.
You can handle the port.
And Akhilesh, to keep on improving his numbers and support the team. When I say support the team, that means Summit's Business Technology, so that team should not be worrying about Akhilesh. They should not be, you know, lagging behind to support him. So that's completely on me. We'll be supporting him so that...
Team can meet their own targets, and uh, Akhilesh can add on his numbers to meet collectively team's target.
Yeah.
And from my ITBD standpoint, my continued emphasis is to connect with him, support him, so that if he needs any clarity, of course he raises his hand, he voices out where he needs clarity, where he needs understanding.
So that I assist him with all the knowledge and understanding he requires on a real-time basis.
Anything from anyone?
I do not want the silence that is set up.
No, I mean, things are, you know, you want me? I can complain some if you want.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm good at that, you know that.
No.
Yeah.
Trust me, at ITBD, yeah, at ITBD, I mean, you know, someone shared the other day, so we are not taking feedback as feedback, but feed forward, so that when we hear some feedback, you know, Das definitely gives us a room for improvement, because sometimes we ourselves.
No, we understand it.
I do not watch his boards, you know, every hour. So, and during my 15 minute or 20 minute connect, whatever knowledge, whatever understanding I grasp by looking at his board or getting insights from him, so this is what I get. But so when I, when we speak to you, we get your perspective, how you see things.
from your glance. So that's really important for us to understand.
This is how uh makes us.
That was the nicest way to explain Jason's complaints. I like it. It's very sweet.
Yeah.
You know.
Okay.
What I know about Jason, he's always black and white. I had never seen any grayish feedback from him. So if he's saying things are moving in good direction, I totally, I blindly trust that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, no news for me is good news, you know, just with where we've got, you know, Akhil configured to be with Cindy and everything, you know, it just means that I've been able to catch up on a lot of the stuff that I have going on and what I'm able to work on. So, you know.
Yeah, and in addition to the IND.
Natalie, I don't know whether you know. Sorry, Vishal, please.
Thank you. Yeah, in addition to that, I just want to have some conversation with you, Jason, on this one. You know, we really want Marcus to be back. He's doing good and hopefully he will be there to support ITBD to support Summit. But at the same point of time, you may hate me, but I just want to have a solid plan B with us.
right? I just want to ensure because this is health, this is medical, not in anybody's control. Do any XYZ, as they say that, God forbidden, in case if he takes more time to recover. And so are you really good with Akhilesh that he is a solid plan B for you and he's ready to
fill in Marcus shoes gracefully or at any point in time you feel that okay.
If a question you want answered, I can take that back to my team. I'm not the one to answer that, to be quite honest with you, because I'm not the one that is having to, you know, get things out there. And I think that the last connection that we had was that we were going to see, be optimistic one, you know,
Okay.
Yes.
Manish is returned by the end of the month. And if that was not going to be the plan, then we might need to discuss that. So, you know, you all tell me if you if you're if you're thinking right now that that is kind of up in the air and that, you know, we're not we need to do that, then I can take that back to my team. I need to know direct.
Oh.
Uh...
No, I'll nothing. I would say that, you know, nothing is like that. I just want to make sure that, you know, all the options are open with us. I want to be very transparent with you. It should not be like, you know, something, anything should come as a surprise to you. It's too early to see anything. We are really optimistic because he...
Okay.
Why don't I?
I'll just solicit the feedback from folks that, hey, we don't anticipate this, but if we were, if the original plans were to change, how do you feel about the kill? Would this be that, would we want to try to continue to bring him up to speed, or do we feel that we need a different resource?
Yeah.
Yes.
Now, I will be honest with you that if we were to keep...
Yeah.
the kill and things were to work out, right, and we could find ways to utilize them long term, he's definitely not the skill level of Manish. So I could tell you for a fact that my bosses are going to want to discuss that portion of it, like the contract side of things, and you know, because it's not the same level of resource.
Mhm.
So whether or not my support desk and Cindy and my folks can utilize him and get him back up to where it helps on the support desk side, you know, but.
No, fair enough.
You know how bosses are and you know people that write the checks are. They're going to say, oh, we got a less like a less qualified person. How do we end up on that side of the equation? You know, so they're going to be that that will definitely come up if we end up on plan B, I can tell you that.
The.
But I'll find out from Cindy and the folks that are doing the day-to-day, how would that affect our day-to-day? I'm happy to solicit that, you know.
No, absolutely, just want to be very honest and transparent on this page. I really hope that we don't have to follow that path and we are very optimistic with Manish health and he should be back on your account. We just, we definitely want that. It just like that, I just want to ensure that, you know, we are, we all are on the same page as long as we know that we have a solid B plan in place. So I appreciate all the transparency on that, Jason.
Yep.
Kour.
Mm.
No, I understand what you're saying, so.
We'll keep you posted every week at doing that. Yep.
But I will take that back and I'll talk to Cindy. I'll start with Cindy about it and Cindy can let me know what the engineers, the feedback that the engineers have been given, this and that. We're a pretty close knit team. So, you know, we won't say anything to somebody that's going to be outright offensive or upset them, but we will share honest feedback with each other.
Yep.
And, you know, so I'm sure Cindy has a good pulse of what's going on and I can chat with her, you know, on that side of it.
Nope, truly understand that. Thank you so much, Jason. Gagan, over to you.
Hey, Michelle, I'm sharing my screen back. Thank you.
Jim, is it visible to you?
Yes.
Yep, all good.
Priya, thank you.
Okay, so the holiday calendar will remain the same. So, so these are, so whether it's Manish or Akhilesh, so these are the compulsory holidays can be marked on the calendar. And so for now, Akhilesh has chosen Diwali, which is in November. However,
I mean, whether Manish or Akhilesh, I'm saying. So this is the one of the major festivals. So they'll most likely be taking this holiday. However, we'll let you know at least two or three weeks in advance what they have finalized. Thank you.
So do we have any PTO or anything like that for a kill that is coming up?
Not yet. He has not planned. In the next two years, next two weeks, he has not planned any, but we'll let you know.
Sides are okay.
Okay, we'll just have to kind of see how that would work if since we have a resource coming in, if somebody took one and since somebody was going to take the other, we're just going to keep track of that map, I guess. That's all. Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah.
No, definitely. We'll definitely be aligned with our PTO policy. So it is our responsibility to communicate that to you at least two weeks in advance if he's taking one or two PTOs. Yeah.
I just meant if the, if Akhil and then Manish, if when Manish returns, if he took a different holiday, you know what I mean, then Summit might end up with less work days than, you know, but the employee would still be under their policy, you know what I mean?
Mmh.
I get you, yes.
Yeah, but then we cross that bridge if it needs to be. I don't know that we will, so...
Sarah or Natalie, you may probably be able to give better answer on this about service level, you know, service PDO as per service agreement.
No, yeah, as far as the service agreement, you get the 10 holidays and then the total for the India engineers is 22 for like just the PTO combined sick days.
Yep.
And as of now, just starting to Natalie's point, the company holidays, the only upcoming one which we have, that's on 3rd of July and no other ones. Most of them, they are later in the year. Yep.
Yeah, and we're off that anyway. That would have aligned with Manish anyway. It's just, you know, the optional holidays, if they had picked different holidays, Summit may have ended up having less support days, that's all.
Exactly.
That's the, yeah, well.
You won't need to worry. Probably by next month we'll have who will be available.
That will be on us, Jason. We will take care of that. Don't worry about that. We'll definitely plan in a way that, yeah, we will plan in a way this does not affect you or Amit at all, whether this is Marcus or Akhilesh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what I was saying.
Top.
Oh, guys, Diwali's on my birthday.
Kip.
Oh, happy Diwali, Natalie.
It's on my birthday this year. I think I should come to India. Yeah, that's fun.
No.
Will wish you happy Diwali then?
Yeah.
Then we can move next. Any other questions, Jason?
Kip.
Okay, so build it live. I'll hand it over to Natalie. I have already shared the details with Jason during our last meet. Natalie can definitely convince you.
Yeah, Jason, are you going to be able to make it up? You're not too far from Jersey City.
Yeah.
So what I need to do is I need to go through and take a look at the, I guess, agenda. Yeah, I was going to say content. What's the right word? But you know, what's going on on this thing? And then try to see what's relevant to us and see. So if I can't physically make it, and the reason I wouldn't physically make it is because my boss doesn't want
Agenda.
Yeah, I got you.
wants me to not physically go anywhere and he wants to be working. We've got a lot of stuff going on. We might be going to Halo, which is the problem with timing. So we got.
Okay, well, Halo's gonna be, Halo's gonna be at the event, like they're one of our favorite partners, so you can, you can honestly get, you can honestly get time with Tim while you're there, if you're looking at that too.
Yeah, I know.
That's kind of why I was thinking of looking at it, but...
That's why I was thinking of trying to be like, I think I had mentioned that this mail, the content may align with us, but I don't know if...
Yep.
No, for sure. And if you're moving towards AI, like where the whole last day is just going to be an AI boot camp.
Yeah.
So the challenge becomes whether or not I need, the way our contracts with our current systems lie, I mean, I have a super tight deadline to try to make this all happen. So I may not be able to physically get up there for that. Are there any virtual stuff or anything like that?
And...
Be.
To attend, or is this all?
Not really, like if you sign up, you'll get the sessions after. That's really the only, like you can sign up to still get the sessions, but I mean, coming in person and actually being there is going to be the best. Yeah, definitely. I can tell you it's going to be worth it, even just the people that you're going to be talking to.
Yeah, that's what I figured.
That's what I figured, you know.
even if it's just you're at lunch, you're at the bar later, like all the conversations are always going to be good. Sessions are fantastic. Yeah, look at the agenda. It's all sectioned out by each, basically what each section is. So.
I know, I...
Keith.
Okay.
Gagan, if you can just stop the sharing, I can bring it up on the screen right away. And Jason, just for your convenience, I have sent you the link in the chat window right now so that you can go through the agenda and you can also discuss it with the team. And I have also put in the code.
for you so that you can go ahead and if you would like, you will be able to get one complimentary ticket while you will be going to add in the registrations. So this is a...
So just to give you, so I talked with my boss to kind of plant the seed and I don't know that that seed got planted. I'm trying to, you know,
Mhm.
Well, I do you think he would want to come too?
No.
No, I mean, we would, we would love, yeah.
No, no, he doesn't. He wants me to do what I have to do, and he wants my department to run perfectly. He wants me to be successful, too.
Kip.
Yeah, because I mean, there are, it is a lot of CEOs. There's a lot of CEOs that come to our event. Honestly, probably about 50% are actually CEOs. Even more than that.
who are coming in as sponsors there from Focus Technology, Mightyware, OneNet, T Solutions, Turnkey, Red Helm, MSP Corp, all of these would be there. And then similarly, this is what the agenda is. I have shared the link. So for the first day, we have the main stage and the breakouts, where the breakouts will be divided into 4 sections.
Leadership focus on AI accelerator. Similarly, the day two and then the last day three, that specifically focused on our AI accelerator. All the implementation which we have done during the AI, those known cases will be discussed and you can go ahead and utilize it for your.
organization. So this is what the breakout sessions will be focusing on. AI future leadership, operations, growth and sales.
Kip.
Yeah.
Yeah, so really anybody from Summit 2 can make it, because those are the categories of each of the breakout sessions, and there's more happening at each time.
Okay. Well, again, I will revisit this and see what I can do. The timing of the migration really may make it super tough, but I just had to look at what that timeline looks like.
Okay, we appreciate it.
I am super excited though to get over to Halo and get off of all this ConnectWise stuff. They have really done a really bad job over the last few years trying to, they just haven't, they also really got us bad on some automate stuff. Like on a 4th of July holiday. They left us all, all of us on-prem folks, they left us hanging, basically broke our systems.
Mhm.
Oh, yes, yeah.
and said, oh, you gotta fix it. And then we ask questions, like, oh, we don't know the answer. It's like, what are you doing? They stopped signing their own certs and stuff.
Yeah.
You know, for sure, for sure, we we we were happy with the move as well.
Yeah, so we'll see where that sends up.
I mean, I've heard nothing but good things about Halo. We're now on Ninja and not on, you know, Automate. So that's been a really, really nice transition.
But our billing department is on is involved in this next one, so that's the challenge.
Where are you?
Ohh.
Thanks, Gagan. I believe we are good there. Rest, anything else, Jason? Anything which you would like to add in? So feel free to reach out to me, Gagan, Kanav, Vishal, Natalie. All of us think of us as a part of your extended team. You don't have to wait for these monthly calls. You are just a text away.
Das.
No.
Oh, I definitely do that. You know that. I get those tasks I hate. We meet. And you are always very accommodating. I mean, it's wild how quickly you become available for things that I message. So, I mean, for a company that we only have one of your resources, you know, I think that you will really
You.
Yeah.
For sure.
But...
Glad to hear that.
You know, I know all accounts are the same, I guess, are supposed to be, but you guys really do do that. So I really appreciate the partnership and, you know, I'll get my feedback from the team about about Akil and what that would look like if that were to have to be a situation.
But.
I'm not going to talk to my boss about it yet because I don't need that bubbling up yet. I mean, they will be asking for some kind of concessions. I'll tell you that. So I don't want to have to go down that street, but I'll find out as far as the people that actually day to day are working with a kill and see how that would work out.
Yep.
Thank you, Jason. Thanks for your time. Rest you have a great week ahead.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Yep, and if anybody does, talk to Manish.
Yeah, and and and just just want to let you know. Yep, OK.
Yeah, just, you know, tell him that the team is sends us our best. You know, everybody's still asking. Everybody comes to me asking how he's doing, like, you know, at least once or twice a week. So, you know, send our best to him.
Go ahead, go ahead.
I.
I always tell him, yeah, thank you for sharing that, Jason. I always pass my wishes to Manish, and he feels really, really happy when he listens, you know, to about Cindy and Jason, that you know how you're missing him.
Yeah, even my son was asking, like, you know, like he was talking to my son about some of the stuff, like during some of the holidays, he would go on there and talk to my son about some of that stuff. So my son knows him, and even my son was asking, oh, that guy that's been really sick in India, how's he doing? You know, and my son's only 10, so that's, you know, we do really care. So all the business stuff aside, I really hope that he,
Thank you.
Aww.
Khan.
Yeah.
Goodnight.
Thank you.
gets himself up to speed as quick as possible, you know.
I really, really appreciate this partnership and, you know, how you are, you know, keeping him as family. Thank you.
Yeah, of course.
So thank you, Jason, for joining in and spending 3 minutes extra on this call.
All right, we're all blessing.
Kour.
Thank you.
Yep.
Ohh, no problem. Alright, thank you, Team. Yeah, bye one.
Thank you, Jason. Take care.
Thanks, Jason. Thank you.
Thank you, Jason.
Dipon.
Take it.